For Flick Finder, we'll be utilizing
the flickr.photos.search method
of the Flickr API.
This method allows us to search for
images using a text string, or for
images that are geo-tagged
near a certain latitude and
longitude, amongst other things.
Of all the methods in the Flickr API,
this one probably has
the most possibly arguments.
But luckily for us,
we'll only need a few.
Let's start with the arguments
we'll need for a text search.
The only required argument of
course is the API key, but
the next argument of interest is called,
text.
The text argument is used to find images
that have a title, a description or
tags containing a text
value that we provide.
If we continue down,
the next argument that we're
going to use is called safe_search.
What safe_ search will allow us to
do is to filter results to show
only images containing
content that's deemed safe.
The remaining arguments are ones
that we've previously used in
the Sleeping In The L ibrary app, and
I'll show them all in
the API explorer now.
So for text I'm going to
enter the Atlanta Braves,
which is my favorite baseball team.
And then for safe_search, I'll enter 1.
And the last argument I'm
going to specify is for extras.
Again, we need to use
the url_m value in extras so
that we get urls for
medium images in the results.
And before we call this method,
let's change the output type to JSON.
And it looks like there are thousands
of photos for the Braves.
Let's just pick one.
I'll copy the URL into
the address bar and
remove the backslash characters
that were added by Flickr.
Remember these backslashes will get
removed when we create NS URLs.
And there we go, this is
a picture actually of the Brave's
new baseball stadium that's being
built in Cobb County, Georgia.